and we're getting a close work as we're
getting closer to valentine's day jc and
i have been showing you where
you can celebrate around town safely so
far i've taken you to the twilight zone
venice italy at the venetian of course
the wild wild west and now
we're going down under
now this is a special thunder from down
under tree from channel 8
studios okay this is just a preview of
what you can get
at thunder from down under for
valentine's day weekend we've got ryan
alex and jaden thank you for doing that
i was that was nice
oh too bad too bad okay so
i want to start off we'll get to the
single ladies and the single fellas
later but
right now you know valentine's day
weekend of love
for the people who are in a relationship
or who have a valentine
and they want to you know spice things
up ryan
what kind of workouts could they do
right before the night starts
we've got a few things we can start
jaden just doing something that
everybody can do this is just something
a little blood in the chest and the
shoulders this is just a regular push-up
okay this is something everybody can do
and jaden can obviously step it up if
you think you're more advanced than this
oh shoot then jaden this is obviously
next level
whoa uh-oh okay now if you can do that
for valentine's day you you're in for i
think i think your girl will be proud
yeah yeah you're definitely getting some
extras you're definitely gonna get some
actors ryan said okay let's move on to
alex now
thank you jayden for that by the way
you're you look tired you okay you okay
all right alex let's get to the single
ladies now and the single fellas who
might want to join you guys at
thunderland for thunder for down under
this weekend
how can we enjoy it well we hope they
would like to join us for valentine's
day we've got two shows
on the 14th um people are able to buy
tickets through the excalibur box office
or you can go to ticketmaster and get
tickets there as well all right and how
how's the show changed you know since
with the copa 19 regulation
unfortunately we are masked up at the
show i mean it's safest for everybody
and there's a there's a bit more
distance than usual you know we we
normally like to get close but um
we're keeping our distance from the
crowd at the moment as well it's crazy
plenty of eye candy for us
right it's all about walking you can't
mask the whole body
all right well thank you ryan alex jaden
from thunder from down under
i'll see you guys this weekend yeah
don't work that way all right
i wasn't mad at that assignment today no
just keeping it safe and sexy this
weekend
right now